So why don’t you in this unit look at a field
example, if we are applying statistical techniques
for problems of important significance in stock
trading. So here is a stock price for a specific
day in 2010 and the company we’re discussing
is Apple, which on the day started trading just
above $250 but in the afternoon the stock went
all of a sudden down to $200, back to the
original price. As a statistician, we are
concerned about this, because if we make trading
decisions based on what’s happening, we might
lose millions or billions of dollars.
This is a one in a decade abnormal behavior
and as a statistician, we might care about
writing software that finds these kind of
behaviors, so we stop trading and we don’t
fall into the trap of selling our stock at a
unfortunate rate just because something really,
really strange is happening. And that’s a real
example, in which have lost millions if not
billions of dollars.
So on a typical trading day, Apple stock traded
about 70,000 times, giving us 70,000 data points
of prices during the day. What we’d be looking
at is the percentage change between adjacent
trades, which we call Delta T and this defined
as the difference between two consecutive trading
points, XT plus one minus XT normalized by XT.
So normally if XT and XT plus one is the same,
this will be zero. If there is a big difference
then this is a larger value and we know for the
day in question what the mean and the standard
deviation is for this percentage change. The
mean is as small as 0.00074 negative in percent,
so if we leave off the percent it’s even a
hundred times smaller and this is the value
for the standard deviation, 0.01344 percent.
My first question for you is, to compute the
confidence interval, assuming that we can use
a confidence interval to detect outliers in
the data. If you assume a symmetrical confidence
interval with five percent confidence, in our
magic factor that percentile is 1.96; compute
for me in percent the confidence interval
for the variable Delta T.